here we are juniper Hill Inn now who in
the hell would bring an RV all the way
up here
I'm not staying that's telling Hotel
look at it well I got that's beautiful
Wow okay around in the front door
[Music]
can't leave them and clear the snow for
guests to come in you're kidding me
it's locked that's not very welcoming
[Music]
why'd you have a big mansion guests
can't arrive through the front [ __ ]
door Jesus who wants to enter through
the back door mr. Ramsey's here I need
you to do room one right away
well at least this tours over finally
I'm over there how are you black Gordon
please Dean Robert Dean we were you over
there I was at the front door yes okay
this is actually our entrance and in the
winter because of snow really we have to
keep that locked one otherwise the snow
load comes off and kills people kills
people
yeah I can have you killed anyone so no
where's my stuff from
and aftermath of a Antiques Fair yeah
this looks like it could be a beautiful
room
we can't tell because it's tough with so
much clutter that's the reception desk
no why does have what is that that is
our bar right now you are kidding me
this is the bar yes
with what the martinis martinis Oh bless
him made a pig's Pig martini well we
have three rescue pot-bellied pigs you
have three pigs here right what is that
for
were you born with this in your mouth
yeah don't I wish honestly actually no
that was a gift from a giant so yeah
Robert obviously loves the shot all
these expensive antiques but as a guest
I don't feel comfortable I feel like
you're in the museum this is the main
formal dining room
this big chair here is for for one just
kind of we're known as a romantic
destination and just out of interest
however we would move the time moving
please yes so you got a sofa on the
table we thought it was kind of nice to
have like a cozy banquette oh well three
u.s. presidents have dined here already
which once Teddy Roosevelt Calvin
Coolidge Teddy Roosevelt died in here
Wow I wanted to try to give him a little
bit of sense of the history but juniper
Hill Wow okay so that's the dining room
yeah well we have two dining rooms God
you must be busy with two diagrams well
I wish we were busy let see how we have
spurts of being incredibly busy right
where we lack is all the other times
ready yeah
this place looks like a millionaire's
mansion not a strug in business I've got
to scratch beneath the surface this
place per week is telling how much we're
lucky if we're doing you know 15,000 a
month what does it cost to keep the
place open 30
yep so you're losing $200,000 a year
it's been a nightmare we maintained our
room rates thinking that the economy
wouldn't be this long a hall but we've
all experienced those kind of
difficulties and myself including but
you you navigate your way out of that
rotation
unfortunately my partner lost his job we
expected him to have his job for a
little longer
you must have gained a substantial pay
off retirement it's all been put into
this
how much over a million dollars how many
does into this already yes and does he
have an active role in the business he
tries to maintain the accounting and he
helps just about with everything we're
in trouble
trouble you'd never guess from the look
of this place it's more like Buckingham
Palace on Skid Row
do you know what and Robert honestly I
had to go straight to my room if you
have my plan right wow it does it's the
largest colony Revival mansion in New
England the mole paintings and you're in
the Maxwell have art suite which is the
original okay Wow peaceful room
and I mean this is this is a beautiful
but
smell-my seriously it it does smell
different
[ __ ] I mean that is horrific oh my god
it smells like sewage
we had a plumbing issue and I said shut
under the bed and how much this room
goes for three hundred and fifty dollars
a night three hundred and fifty dollars
a night for room the smells of [ __ ]
well you're kidding me we haven't rented
it though lucky how it's been out of use
for four months four months yeah
oh come on it has been this is crazy it
is crazy it just like stems
I gotta get out of here it stinks [ __ ]
it's another room yes I have room -
bloody hell
I didn't realize $350 to be caked in
[ __ ]
[Music]